Ray why did you write this book
in order to understand what's happening
now
um and from my perspective to do my job
well I needed to understand
uh certain things that never happened in
my lifetime
um I learned a while ago that most of
the surprises in my lifetime came from
things that never happened in my
lifetime but happened many times before
in this case there were three big things
that are happening simultaneously the
creation of a lot of debt and the
printing of money to pay for that debt
so there's a financial component to that
spending a lot more money than you're
earning financing it with debt and
printing money the second is uh the
amount of internal conflict uh arising
from the largest wealth gaps and the
largest uh political gaps
um since 1900 and then third heard the
rising of a great power to challenge an
existing great power to compete with in
the form of China challenging the United
States you know the Soviet Union was
never in great economic power and there
are different kinds of power and you
have to have all those powers and so I
needed to go back and study that in the
study of the rise and declines of
Reserve currency so I went back
um to find the Cycles I went back 500
years
um to see the rise and declines of the
empires and their currencies
particularly the Dutch the British the
American and so on
um and I saw
um this big cycle I also studied the
dynasties in China since the tong
Dynasty starting a little after the year
600 and I saw this same pattern I could
sort of describe the pattern if you like
but I was motivated uh to do that and so
it popped out loudly and clearly so I
did the study for for my internal
handling my responsibilities but when I
learned what I learned I thought I
should pass it along and that became the
book